welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and ahead of Loki season 2 perhaps
the biggest question on viewers Minds is
the character of Victor timely a Kang
variant first revealed in the
post-credits scene of Ant-Man and the
WASP Quantum media who we assumed would
be the villain of these upcoming Loki
episodes but increasingly sounds like a
more complex figure I think we all need
a further explanation of who Victor
timely is where he's coming from while I
had you covered on the MCU version of
the character I think we need a real
expert on the comics lore so we reached
out to another YouTuber you might know
Benny from comic story and get in here
how's it going Eric good Benny I'm so
glad you're here I'm relieved because
there's a lot to know about what the
comics have done well Victor timely to
make this simple is just Kang so that's
it I'll guess I'll go okay bye this was
great anyway subscribe to Comic
historian subscribe okay yeah yeah yeah
okay so resetting the timeline here
there's got to be more to them right oh
there definitely is more to Victor
timely kind of you see the way the MCU
is doing it is every version of of Kang
is a separate character from a separate
timeline but in the early days of comics
all time travelers were just one version
of Kang in a different point within his
timeline okay so after his initial
defeat by The Avengers Kang decided to
go back to 1901 and take all the
knowledge he has about Robotics and
steam and all kinds of stuff and become
Victor timely to create a city that he
could grow in chronopolis chronopolis I
don't know how to pronounce that and I
think both are right both are right okay
syndrome it's it's not a problem but he
creates a city that he's going to use to
eventually conquer time Victor timely
really only shows up for one annual and
then kind of pops up in a few other
weird Kang events but always acts like
he's not Kang and that's because early
days a lot of these characters weren't
Kang until much farther in the writing
process but that's not really what
matters Victor timely's big contribution
to everything is during hang Dynasty he
basically is the guy that created a back
door in to every robotic every character
everything that had any kind of like
semblance of robotic stuff the big one
being the Sentinels and that's how he
was able to take over during Kang
Dynasty Kang Dynasty is like eight
different King plots all rolled up into
one including an underground battle
thing going on on top of all of that but
that's a different story for a different
day Victor timely is gone at that point
he just was the guy that affected
everything going on in Kang Dynasty and
used as a reference point so there's a
lot to know and there's a Comics version
of Kang Dynasty that might not be what
the film The Kang Dynasty is doing they
might just have taken that name almost
guarantee you it won't be with the
amount of things that happen in that if
you don't know King Dynasty ends with a
giant Kang fighting a giant Captain
America in the middle of space right so
does that sound like something that the
movie is gonna do no well there will be
Sentinels at that point in the MCU
probably not right so together at the
end of this video we are going to
recommend which specific Marvel comic
story lines that you really need to read
to prepare for the season of Loki cause
do we need to read all of them honestly
no I did binge read a whole bunch of
them before this the biggest issue with
a lot of these early Kang story lines is
the Kang storyline which changed as it
was going so characters like a mortise
when they're first introduced don't even
act like Kang or that they're
referencing Kang or anything they're
trying to manipulate Kang only for us to
later discover a mortise is actually a
king timeline I don't want to say
variant because variants are MCU and
that's a separate timeline but it is
Kang but that's not referenced or really
brought up until Avengers forever and
then an Avengers forever they use comic
book mumbo jumbo to separate the
characters anyway the biggest issue with
a lot of these old Kang story lines is
they're from like the 70s and the 60s
and so they just don't read easily and
it's kind of a slog to get through so I
really can't recommend any of the old
Kang story lines and specifically I
think there might be a later King
storyline that the film studio is more
interested in and by the way this is
actually part of a collaboration new
rock stars and comic story and are doing
right now you can see me over on the
comic story and channel in an episode of
the problem with we are talking about
Loki comics and Loki in the MCU and why
Tom hiddleston's take on the character
on screen seems to work whereas the
comics have struggled so uh be sure to
check out Benny's appearance in the
break room so yeah let's talk about the
MCU version of Victor timely and
everything we know about him in Loki
season 1 the Kang variant known as he
remains warned Loki and Sylvie about his
other variants if you think I'm
evil just wait
till you meet bye variance we meet some
of those variants in the mid credit
scene of Batman to watch quantumania
showing it's the Kang Dynasty led by
immortus Pharaoh Rama touch Scarlet
Centurion and this Arena filled with
kangs this imagery was taken directly
from 1988's Avengers 292 by Walt
Simonson Pennsylvania now a smaller
Council of Kansas actually introduced
earlier in 1986 as Avengers 267 but the
big arena showed up in uh 292 in 1988.
it again very weird because it was not
so much of a Kang storyline it was like
more of a Neymar story but then we just
go to these other Pages where it's Kang
for a second well it just continually
anytime they wanted to do time travel
they would make new Time Travelers and
then as time went on the writers decided
what if they're all just Kang yeah what
if Every Time Traveler's a version of
Kang in his timeline exactly so that's
kind of what the MCU is trying to
reconcile as well the second of the two
quantumania credit scenes the
post-credits scene was actually seen
from the upcoming Loki season this is
when Loki Mobius attend this Expo hosted
by Victor timely the sign reading Victor
timely and his astounding temporal
Marvels he tells This Crowd undressed
attendees hi
is
every
thing
it shapes our lives but perhaps
we can shape
it really chewing the scenery with the
pauses between the words there Majors
but we know from Loki season 2 footage
that this setting is actually the 1893
World's Fair in Chicago so instead of
1901 in timely Wisconsin Marvel Studios
has placed Victor timely at a famous
time and place in real world history
which that's an important change I think
because in the comics Victor timely
correct me if I'm wrong chose 1901
specifically because he wanted to
conquer the 20th century starting with
like the first year that was his entire
goal get ahead of everybody so that he
can manipulate all robotics right that
was an important year he's kind of like
a Jules vernian board a challenge seeker
yes just trying to find something new to
do but 1893 Chicago seems like a
specific choice in other ways for one it
ties Loki to real world historical
curiosity so as season one did with the
destruction of Pompeii and 79 A.D the DB
Cooper hijacking 1971. also the Chicago
World's Fair was the world's first
ferris wheel and it was a backdrop of
murders by the infamous serial killer
H.H Holmes will the show tie into that
God I hope so it'd be fun to get a
reference to him but really it just
seems like Marvel Studios wants to
characterize Victor timely is one of the
great innovators in America at the turn
of the century kind of like Thomas
Edison Nikola Tesla Victor timely sign
with its mention of temporal Marvels
reminds me of Professor Marvel from The
Wizard of Oz go with me on this Benny I
know I do this and viewers hate it but
um we're going to The Wizard of Oz We're
Going Down The Yellow Brick Road all
right I'm down with this we have to so
Professor Marvel played by Henry Morgan
he's a traveling con artist a magician
who served as the analog for the wizard
himself and actually plays multiple
characters in the film like the wizard
himself and the Emerald City gatekeeper
who hang that Bell and in in Sam raimi's
2013 film odds of Great and Powerful a
film that oddly cameoed in the MCU in
episodes of One Division James Franco's
take on the wizard Begins the film and a
similarly Shifty Miracle Worker barking
at a crowd of gawkers I bring up these
examples not just because I'm going off
on a tangent although that is something
that we do in the problem with and it's
fun it's what we like to do yes and I
just do this though because I think the
Wizard of Oz was totally an influence on
the portrayal of he who remains in Loki
season 1 as a man behind the curtain and
Sam Raimi directed Doctor Strange is
Multiverse Madness and is being rumored
to be directing Avengers Secret Wars so
it just kind of helps to know everything
that's in that cinematic DNA even if
like we forget it after we watched this
video I'm always amazed at the
connections that you I never thought
we'd be going down Wizard of Oz while
I'm here with you it's tenuous but I
think it's important Wizard of Oz was
arguably the most important story in
this era of America in the late 19th
century and early 20th century you've
convinced me I'm gonna go re-watch all
the Wizard of Oz stuff oh one shot
energy huh I think I'll try it
whoa
[Applause]
so what is one shot's focused shoe do
[Music]
hey Charlie
so uh one shot really is all you need
begin your transformation with one shot
energy today by going to
oneshotenergy.com new rockstars for 10
off your order by placing Victor timely
at a trade show in the 1893 Chicago
World's Fair I think Marvel Studios is
trying to connect him to that same
history that Tony Stark and his father
Howard Stark were a part of because 1893
that year would be exactly 50 years a
nice round number 50 years prior to the
Stark Expo in Queens in 1943 where Steve
Rogers and Bucky Barnes saw Howard Stark
unveil his early Repulsor technology and
that levitating car didn't levitate that
long but at this Expo there was also an
exhibit for a synthetic man presented by
Dr Phineas Horton which was a nod to the
original Android form of the Human Torch
that was built by Denise Horton this
Human Torch was a member of the Invaders
alongside Steve Rogers bookie Barnes and
Neymar back in the early days of timely
comics in the late 30s early 40s and in
Avengers one two three to one three five
and 1975 by Steve engelhardt artist Neil
Adams pitched the idea that the Visions
Android corpse originally came from
Ultron 5 finding that original Android
human torches corpse wiping in of its
memories and reactivating it as the
vision so that 1992 Victor Timely comic
storyline retcon's history so that
Phineas Horton was mentored by Victor
timely so we kind of see some
connections forming here possibly with
the MCU Victor timely at the 1893 Expo
50 years before the 43 Stark Expo which
had Phineas Horton and his synthetic man
exhibit there are just I think enough
Dots here to infer that Marvel Studios
might be trying to draw a line between
everything among everything I should say
in the comics itself Victor timely
actually has a hand in creating the
original Human Torch which then becomes
the basis for vision right so it's
already there all the pieces are in
place and I think by putting him at this
Expo that's Marvel Studios saying hey
remember phase one remember Howard Stark
and and Steve Rogers at that Expo we're
doing the same kind of thing just 50
years earlier I think they're all going
to be part of a connected historical
timeline with Victor timely starting it
all in 1893. okay so here we go time for
some recommendations Benny based on all
this info we have to give the viewers
one comic storyline from each of us
before Loki season two what do we think
Marvel Studios cares most about when it
comes to adapting Kang Victor timely all
these different variants on screen well
if you want to read something more
current with Kang Kang himself does have
his own mini-series which was really
good and very well received he also
shows up in this is going to sound
random he's in venom venom since he just
became the king of the Symbiotes also
has the ability to travel through time
space and different dimensions and to
teach him to do that is Kang but if you
do want to read a classic Kang storyline
I don't recommend Celestial Madonna I
don't recommend the older stuff because
it's just too wordy it's too full and
even if you know what's going on it gets
retconned as you read more and more of
them which makes the older stuff far
more confusing but you can read Kang
Dinosaur King Dynasty is the storyline
where he finally does a big push to try
and conquer the world but you need to
remember it's a late 90s comic book
storyline so it's got like 15 issues and
four different story lines happening
concurrently at the exact same time but
there is a core story you can follow on
that one yeah yeah I think it's good to
read at least the comic storyline that
they took the title from because there's
going to be some elements you gotta
imagine a lot of the screenwriters who
tackle these things they are discovering
the comics the way the rest of the world
are discovering these Comics not all
them grew up reading these issues so
they they're gonna like pick and choose
what narrative elements work for the
Cinematic story they're trying to tell I
mean the core idea of King Dynasty is
that through things like Victor timely
and ramatut and immortus through time
itself he has set everything up for the
big Invasion right which sounds like we
could be doing that with Loki absolutely
like the version of the Kang Dynasty
that we saw in that big arena yeah they
might have been working together to just
like plant little uh treasure caches
throughout history and weapons caches to
kind of work collectively to best set up
the future that benefits all of them so
I think it is useful to read that
storyline but personally my favorite and
I've mentioned this in videos before but
I think what might be the best Kang
storyline from the past 10 years at
least the one that I think inspired
Marvel Studios just because the decision
making pivoting to Kings would have
started a few years after the this
storyline came out is the 2017 Avengers
Unleashed Kang War storyline and I just
think the art in this is so good so this
is uh written by Mark Wade but the Arts
by Mike del mundo and uh the the
specific form of pharaoh Rama Tut on the
jean jacket and Moon Knight was taken
directly from Del Mundo's art of
theoromatite but this is just a really
cool Vision storyline where the Avengers
just start getting pruned out of time
and are it's from their point of view
they don't understand what's going on
but we realized that Kang has this Kang
variant Kang Prime at the end of all
time who has specifically been
orchestrating all of it all the
different Kang variants now a lot of
King story lines try to reconcile all
the different uh versions and
incarnations of Kang over time but I
think this one does it the best visually
to show like the kind of spectrum of
kangs but we learned that like vision is
just really good at like Computing
through the future and it's I think one
of my favorite Vision story lines of the
comics because he is kind of this
heartless sentient Android right and he
has to make the decision of do we kill
Kang as a baby they apply they're like
Hitler baby a paradox to it and uh it
has like the best ending of the way they
defeat Kang and I won't spoil it but
like this is one where they don't just
like whack-a-mole him out of existence
not thinking that he's gonna pop back up
somewhere they find like a really weird
like specific way to write Kang out of
like out of his villainous timeline so I
highly recommend it and I think like if
we if I was just looking at the
characters who are on the playing board
and the MCU right now you have Vision
you have Hercules you have Sam Wilson
Captain America looking exactly as he
does now in the MCU as he as he did in
that era of the comic so yeah I would
just say even if they don't pull it for
the movie uh it's just a great read so
check it out I mean all you would have
to do is end the King Dynasty movie with
the fight of you know Sam Wilson Captain
America battling against a giant Kang
and you could do your storyline and we
just have like a giant Kaiju Battle with
the characters of the ending we don't
have enough Kaiju battles that's in Moon
Knight right Moonlight was the only
Kaiju Battle we had and I dug it yeah so
there you go giant Sam Wilson giant Kang
slugging it out in space at the end of
the entire movie I think that could say
DMC we just predicted the ending think
we did we spoiled it for you but again
we go a lot further into Loki in the
comics in the episode of the problem
with over on Benny's Channel comic story
and available now subscribe to
comicstorian and check out all of any
great video content buy his hot sauce
thank you yes hot sauce is awesome it's
way better than McDonald's Loki sweet
and sour sauce that stuff's garbage uh
but subscribe to all three channels of
the new rockstars Network you can
support us with some merch over at
nerdright.shop like this Ahsoka fulcrum
shirt we'll have some Loki designs too I
think you can follow me at eavos follow
Benny iconic story and thanks for
watching Benny this has been awesome
it's been a blast can't wait to see you
again and we'll see you next time bye
everybody bye everybody
[Music]